hi my name is Gibby look I'm the
executive director of Accenture
development partnership censures
not-for-profit arm and it's been a
really interesting week here at the
weapon in India it'll change actually
from from last year some of the you know
amazing growth stories of India over the
past few years have obviously been met
with some challenges there's been a lot
of talk around Challenger and corruption
challenges around the business enabling
environment and I deal more in some of
the the socio-economic issues such as
education access to healthcare etc I was
in a particularly interesting session
around education I had today and this is
something that's as close to my heart
because the stakes are really quite
staggering India if it gets its act
together could actually be providing
about a quarter of the global talent
pool by 2025 2030 and currently with so
many kids out of school with huge
shortage of teachers 400,000 I believe
absenteeism and the teaching ranks we
actually need to to address this issue
not as a csr issue for business this is
not social as a strategic issue for
businesses because organizations like
like my own Accenture we have 90,000
people in India today and if we don't
have access to two people to to actually
help your business grow in the future
then that's actually going to put that
that growth at risk so I don't think we
can be passive followers I don't think
we can wait for business to to wait for
government to get this right with for
NGOs to get this right wait for
government to get it right I think we
have to start to engage further up the
value chain of talent to co-invest
co-create the new solutions bring our
technologies to actually ensure that in
India and elsewhere around the world
that we actually have access to
qualified skilled talent not just
enrollment rates the government and the
UN can worry about that we're interested
in the talent the outcome and the skills
that will grow our business in the
future and it's been a great experience
here at web I've enjoyed it and we'll be
looking forward to be coming back next
year